[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi 22 janvier
c'est le résultat d'une carte blanche
dana ramène à capturer le mouvement des
danseurs circassiens pour une série de
photographies
les clichés sont exposés à la
commanderie le centre de musique baroque
de versailles recherchent ces nouveaux
chanteurs la maîtrise forme chaque année
une soixantaine de jeunes du chemin à la
troisième nous avons rencontré quatre
d'entre eux et l'association hélio nous
prend l'air jusqu'au 3 février 50 de ces
artistes sont rassemblés à l'espace
decaux villes de voisins-le-bretonneux
qu'on présente et sculptures et
peintures pour sa nouvelle exposition la
commanderie a fait appel un photographe
artiste associé jusqu'en 2020 dan ramène
s'est interrogé sur le corps et le
mouvement
une vingtaine de clichés qui décryptait
décompose les gestes et notamment ceux
de la danse
capturé un instant un mouvement 26 chez
sont rassemblés autour de la danse
principalement dan ramène s'est attaché
à plusieurs compagnies en résidence ou
en représentation avec la mission danse
de saint quentin en yvelines
l'idée c'est d'être croiser aussi les
artistes que nous programmons et puis
les rencontres se font ne se font pas et
là ça c'est fait il se trouve que notre
partenariat avec la mission danse ça a
été de le faire qu'ils puissent
rencontrer des chorégraphes donc il a
assisté à il a rencontré plusieurs
chorégraphies la cité à plusieurs
spectacles avec ses photographies d'al
ram n entrent au coeur du geste et de
l'impression qu'il laisse son exposition
est le résultat d'une rencontre avec les
équipes de la commanderie
c'était une carte blanche donc ça fait
un an qu'il y travaille et je ne pouvais
pas préjuger du résultat plastique
puisqu'il s'agissait d' expérimenter
corps et mouvements donc ça pouvait être
corps mouvement corps en mouvement
encore c'est lui qui a choisi comme il a
expérimenté plusieurs choses il ya des
choses qui sont floues et des choses qui
sont extrêmement précises extrêmement
nettes et ça donne un ensemble hyper
cohérent et c'est une partie de la
réponse à la question aux questions
qu'il s'est posé d'hui avec ces clichés
le temps semble suspendu le mouvement
las comme une trace fantomatique pour un
autre tour s'interroger sur l'empreinte
qu'on peut laisser
[Musique]
des happy hour à la grande celle dans
son touchard se dévoile un peu plus au
prisme d'elancourt
le jazzman est en concert le 26 janvier
prochain pour son premier album classe
moyenne et il est avec nous en plateau
bonjour bonjour alors votre genre
musical c'est le jazz que vous jouez et
composer mais dans votre album sorti il
ya à peine plus d'un an donc va classe
moyenne on trouve aussi des touches
orientales un soupçon musique classique
c'est ce que vous aimez marier les
genres tout à fait oui ça fait ça fait
très longtemps que que j'ai envie de
marier les genres j'ai commencé
notamment par jouer en duo avec un
violoncelliste batterie violoncelle les
deux univers des instruments étant assez
différents et rarement associés
s'étaient c'était une volonté de marier
ses joueurs est là dans ce disque là
vraiment je j'ai poussé cette idée assez
loin et pour le concert de samedi
justement il y aura mon quintet qui est
un quintet assez jazz qui intègre un
violoncelle
voilà et en plus trois instruments à
vent hautbois clarinette et basson donc
qui vont compléter le mix entre
classique et jazz
c'est votre premier album il est il
était longtemps mûri de toutes ces
expériences de ces rencontres peut-être
oui oui oui oui oui je il ya beaucoup de
morceaux les premiers morceaux j'ai dû
les composés il ya vraiment plusieurs
années donc ça ça a été assez long oui
bon en plus je suis batteur donc j'ai un
accès à la composition un peu
particulier même si je fais du piano et
de la guitare
par ailleurs ça m'a pris un certain
temps voilà donc ça a été
l'aboutissement d'un
mon travail j'ai fait c'est que vous
avez vécu au maroc on joue du jazz en
europe on s'en inspire dans ses propres
caisses oui oui oui il ya eu pas mal de
mariage d'ailleurs entre la musique
marocaine et le jazz notamment les les
musiques gnawa qui sont d'une confrérie
marocaine de transe à la fois quasiment
thérapeutique et festive en même temps
et cette musique a souvent été associé
notamment au jazz il ya des grands
jazzmen coquillon qui ont travaillé qui
ont fait ces mariages là oui tout à fait
c'est plusieurs minutes qu'on parle de
l'album je propose qu'on écoute en
express plaisir
[Musique]
toulouse
alors là c'était renaissance et dans
votre album vous rythmer la vie
quotidienne il y a les objets du
quotidien la ville nouvelle
pourquoi en fait c'est mon premier album
donc j'avais envie de de définir un
petit peu mon identité à travers cet
album peut-être de relater certains
événements n'ont pas recours est donc
donc voilà en fait
villenouvelle d'ouvrir enfin c'est pas
le deal c'est pas l'ouverture du disque
mais de de parler de la vie nouvelle
c'était une évocation de là où j'ai vécu
là où j'ai grandi
après il ya un petit peu d'humour
évidemment aussi dans le dans le titre
du de l'album qui est classe moyenne il
ya beaucoup de beaucoup de musiciens de
jazz qui ceux qui ceux qui font
référence à des origines je sais pas à
new york que les et moi finalement je
viens voilà nos banlieues un peu
classique un peu et se trouvé ça presque
rigolo finalement de mettre ça en avant
comme si la banalité la simplicité on
pouvait en partir de ça vous nourrissez
de votre passé pour composer sa oui oui
bah toute façon ça ça je pense que on ne
peut pas éviter de faire ça
c'est bien on parlait tout à l'heure de
ce mélange de genre musical et notamment
ça se voit dans vos influences mais j'ai
lu avishai cohen brad mehldau en t1
borat
excusez moi pour les trois stations et
jean sébastien bach
mais je pense qu'on peut pas faire un
plus grand écart quand même oui alors
oui non parce que pas tant que ça parce
que alors évidemment bac n'a pas joué de
jazz de brad mehldau mais par contre
l'inversé est vrai brad brad mehldau ou
comment avishai cohen utilise beaucoup
d'éléments du clasico aussi dans leur
musique et pour ce qui est d'avis chez
les coen il utilise énormément aussi de
musiques traditionnelles de pays
différents
et voilà tout ce mélange là c'est ça qui
m'intéresse mais on a entendu quelques
quelques de notes tout à l'heure j'ai la
sensation que vous proposez un jazz très
doux presque contemplatif vous voulez
amené la perse le public à se poser
peut-être à oublier aussi petit cette
ville oui oui oui peut-être ça je sais
pas contemplatif
il ya des choses qui sont aussi assez
rythmé par un peu le morceau qu'on a
diffusé la serre naissance et des
rythmiques marocaines qui sont utilisés
là dedans
dans ce morceau là mais c'est vrai qu'en
général j'aime bien
j'aime bien les choses qui sont assez
écrite assez
[Musique]
assez travaillé assez sophistiqué son
sens sans explosion même s'il ya quand
même quelques passages même free free
c'est à dire improvisé librement pour
l'improvisation il des artistes se
lancent ah oui mais l'improvisation dans
le jazz elle peut prendre plusieurs
formes et notamment la forme
d'improviser sur des choses sur des
thématiques qui sont exposés et dans
tous les morceaux qu'on a là il ya de
l'improvisation qui est même si ça se
ressent peut-être pas complètement en
fait il ya énormément de l'improvisation
la batterie c'est votre instrument où il
avait tout à l'heure que vous découvrez
à 7 au 13 ans mais pourquoi la patrie
honnêtement je crois que la batterie en
fait on a en été avec quelques copains
et on a divisé
le groupe qu'on allait monter c'est à
dire qu'on a 10 bat toi moi j'ai dit bah
moi je vais faire la batterie j'ai un
copain qui avait démarré la guitare et
puis un autre qui a dit bon bah je vais
faire la basse et voilà la patrie
arriver à composer par la batterie c'est
à dire j'ai lentement de la batterie
celle qui vous a mené vers le jazz ou
pas du tout
alors la batterie m'a mené vers le jazz
mais par contre c'est pas la batterie
qui m'a mené la composition je pense que
la composition c'est venu plus tôt parce
que je faisais de la guitare et aussi
parce que j'étais au conservatoire de
versailles dans les classes de sylvain
beuf saxophoniste directeur de cette
classe et et on avait de la composition
à faire j'ai composé un petit peu sous
la contrainte au début et puis en fait
ça m'a plu beaucoup alors on a à peu
près par le temps mais on vous connaît
pas mal aux prises mais quand même il
n'y a pas que le concert du 26 janvier
ce que vous occupez de la programmation
jazz
oui alors monsieur jazz pas tout à fait
je m'occupe pas de toute la
programmation jazz du prisme je
m'implique de notamment ce qui se passe
au piano bar du prisme et où il ya un
concert toutes les semaines tous les
jeudis d'ailleurs jeudi en or 1 jeudi 24
là je vous invite à venir et donc
effectivement je m'occupe de cette
programmation là précisément où
également je joue avant et après les
spectacles cas ce soir
à vous écouter vous manqués alors merci
de visiter notre invitation
ce soir le 24 janvier et surtout le 26
janvier pour votre concert on reste dans
la musique
est ce que votre enfant aime chanter si
oui la maîtrise du cmvm cmbv pardon et
peut-être pour lui le centre de musique
baroque de versailles organise ce
week-end une journée portes ouvertes
pour découvrir le quotidien des pages
ces jeunes du ce1 à la troisième une
première étape avant un recrutement à la
rentrée prochaine
nous avons rencontré quatre pages
actuellement en troisième
[Applaudissements]
lena clélia guillot timothée son page au
centre de musique baroque de versailles
les pages ce sont les enfants à partir
de la sixième qui vont assurer
production et confrères ils ont tous les
4 14 ans et sont élèves de troisième moi
personnellement j'étais assez petit
j'étais en cp avec cet effet ciel de sa
marge et mais je savais juste que
j'aimais chanter que pas que ça me
plaisait de chanter quoi c'était mon
frère qui était d'abord au cmv et mes
parents ont décidé de m'inscrire aussi
ce jour là ils répètent sous la
direction d'olivier schneebeli le
directeur musical et pédagogique de la
maîtrise le 21 février et chanteront
philippe hersant à radio france
c'est vraiment de déjà de fonder
vraiment un groupe de fonder un groupe
et donc que chacun se sente responsable
au sein du groupe donc à différents
niveaux de responsabilité évidemment je
peux avoir la même exigence avec des
jeunes 6e qu'avec des grands troisième
avec ce
ce sentiment qu'on développe chez eux ça
ça amène à plus de plaisir ça mène à
moins compter le temps qu'on passe en
répétition voilà ils ont ils sont
toujours en soif d'être là de montrer
qu'ils savent faire
la maîtrise et en cham les classes à
horaires aménagés
le matin ils sont à l'école et au
collège l'après-midi cours de chant et
répétitions cmbv on va au collège
généralement de 8 heures à 13 heures ou
14 heures et puis on arrive au sel mais
vais juste après on commence la
répétition
après généralement on a une pause d'une
demi heure et jusqu'à 17h 17h30 on
continue de la répétition
c'est peut-être 3 3 4 heures par jour et
c'est comme des cours normaux donc j'ai
fait un peu une sorte de petite troupe
vocale qui va se retrouver donc ici
quatre après midi par semaine les lundi
mardi jeudi et vendredi qui va leur
donner l'occasion de donner de très beau
concert à la chapelle royale du château
de versailles
mais aussi des tournées en france et à
l'étranger
les rendez vous à la chapelle royale ce
sont les jeudis musicaux 24 sont
organisées sur la saison 2018-2019 de
novembre à juin une dernière répétition
avant de se produire devant une salle
pleine
un moment de stress malgré l'habitude
les preuves sont là pour ça et entre
mauger on a un petit geste qui est tu
nous souhaite bonne chance
moi j'étais stressée je trouve 5e
4e mais après petit à petit on prend
goût et on s'habitue pas avoir un
certain nombre de publier un certain
nombre de personnes en face de nous un
loisir passion pour certains une volonté
d'en faire son métier plus tard pour
d'autres
près de 60 enfants sont chaque année en
classe à horaires aménagés sur
versailles le recrutement débute au
niveau du ce1 jusqu'au 27 janvier
corinne c'est ce qu'à présent plusieurs
de ces monotypes à la galerie saint
simon à versailles elle travaille sur
une plaque de métal sans gravure et
créer des modèles inédits grâce à une
vieille presse artisanale des oeuvres
réalisées autour du corps humain du
mouvement je travaille sur les émotions
en fait qu'est-ce qui m'ont c'est la
diversité des émotions et je passe par
le corps se cherche un langage sur le
monotype pour un langage pour exprimer
dans le corps sur les inversions de deux
hanches la puissance de l'émotion aussi
en essayant de par exemple de partir un
pied propulser la tête et le mouvement
parce que le mouvement c'est la
puissance c'est le moi qu'il faut que je
l'inscrivent quoi fonctionne scripps qui
m'ont bien comme quand même motion sur
ma plaque en janvier 1989 théâtre
alexandre dumas est fondé à saint
germain en laye pour ses 30 ans le site
se prépare à trois jours festifs du 25
au 27 janvier et pour en parler nous
sommes par téléphone avec sophie bauer
la directrice déléguée du théâtre
bonjour bon formule à nu alors pour ses
30 ans le théâtre se refait une beauté
le public va pouvoir découvrir une
exposition photographique dans un foyer
totalement rénové c'est bien ça oui
exactement nous avons renouvelé
entièrement ce foyer nous l'avons rendu
plus chaleureux nous allons pouvoir le
découvrir vendredi à 20 heures
exactement puisque nous inaugurons à la
fois ce foyer rénové
nous inaugurons également fait
exposition photographique qui va nous
montrer les coulisses et les secrets du
théâtre un parent 30 amateurs du photo
club de saint germain en laye nous
allons également assister à une
conférence autour des 30 derniers
et dans le spectacle vivant c'est ça
c'est ces trois jours assez chargé et
vous offrait aussi un spectacle au
public une création du cirque leroux
exactement un spectacle qui s'appelle et
les femmes d'une zone rouge alors c'est
une création qui a déjà une grande
renommée puisque ils ont fait énormément
de tourner l'année dernière c'est un
spectacle a rencontré un énorme succès
public
donc on va dire on est parti sur une
valeur très sûre qui a déjà vraiment
rencontré un vraiment un très très bel
écho est vrai que c'est un spectacle qui
est pour le coup extrêmement
spectaculaire une technicité absolument
fabuleuse course et circassiens ils sont
au nombre de quatre dans un décor qui va
vraiment rendre hommage aux capacités
techniques du théâtre à son grand
plateau qui fait plus de 500 m² avec
notamment à l'immense machinois dans
lequel les les circassiens vont pouvoir
effectuer des politiques qui fait plus
de 12 mètres de haut et donc voilà un
très bel une très belle proposition pour
trois représentations samedi à 15 heures
et à 20 heures dimanche à 15 heures et
c'est vrai que c'est un spectacle tient
à coeur parce qu'il est au di lire et
transgénérationnelle il va parler à
toutes les générations
alors pour cet anniversaire on doit
revenir un petit peu sur l'histoire du
théâtre
il porte le nombre d'alexandre dumas et
si je comprends bien c'est pas un choix
anodin
non pas du tout ce n'est pas un choix
anodin puisque alexandre dumas a fondé
en théâtre à saint germain en laye c'est
vrai qu'il avait souhaité ouvrir un
théâtre à paris à l'époque ça n'avait
pas fonctionné
quand il s'est installé au château donc
juste à côté à marly-le-roi c'est vrai
qu'il a il a voulu s'installer à saint
germain au niveau théâtre et c'est vrai
que c'est un théâtre qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui nous avons des traces
d'archivés on va dire
il n'était pas très loin du théâtre
actuel actuelle qui a été fondée il ya
30 ans bien sûr mais c'est vrai que
c'est un théâtre qui a eu un énorme
échos bien que paris l'a un peu jalouse
et voilà donc on a voulu rendre hommage
à cette le théâtre actuel celui
d'aujourd'hui c'est près de 27000 aux
spectateurs chaque année plus de 50
spectacles tout au long de la saison
c'est des chiffres qui dure depuis
oui c'est même un peu plus aujourd'hui
on est presque à 28000 sectateurs et
c'est vrai que c'est un succès de
fréquentation qui s'est jamais démenti
on a un truc très fidèle il ya des
personnes qui nous suivent vraiment
depuis l'origine depuis trente ans on a
un public qui se renouvelle bien sûr
puisqu'on on fait beaucoup d'efforts de
communication direction de la jeunesse
en direction des familles c'est une
population assez majoritaire sur saint
germain et son territoire donc on est
assez fiers de cette fréquentation elle
est même en hausse là où peut-être
plusieurs théâtres bassin petit peu nous
on a vraiment réussi à renouveler public
en adaptant d'otaries et en proposant
une programmation pluridisciplinaire
également vraiment et c'est sur la
musique d'aujourd'hui sur les opéras
d'aujourd'hui sur la danse plus
contemporaines sur du théâtre qui
n'hésite pas à lorgner vers la danse
vers le ver du cirque également vers la
vidéo
donc on essaye d'avoir les les créations
les plus représentatifs du spectacle
vivant actuelle merci sophie bauer je
vous laisse donner la touche finale avec
toutes les équipes du théâtre et pour ne
rien manquer de ce week-end de fête le
programme est à retrouver sur le site
internet qui s'affiche actuellement
merci merci à vous et bonne soirée une
nouvelle fera bientôt ils sont 50 à
rassembler à voisins le bretonneux
l'association hélianthe prend l'air pour
une exposition
ces artistes présentent plusieurs de
leurs oeuvres sculptures peintures des
sens un moyen de se faire connaître au
delà du parc naturel de la haute vallée
de chevreuse
là où ils sont tous installés
l'exposition est à découvrir jusqu'au 3
février à la maison de covile montre
elle a différé la diversité de tous les
talents de nos artistes en fête pour
certains qui sont de renommée
internationale et d'autres qui ont une
renommée locale
c'est vraiment une façon de donner un
aperçu de ce vivier chaque artiste avait
la liberté de choisir les offres qu'ils
voulaient
tu correspondent et surtout à l'espace
qui lui était imparti
pour commencer cet agenda à concert
solidaire ce dimanche 27 janvier le
lion's club et l'encours à quoi lina
reçoit un groupe de gospel spirit à
l'église saint médard à elancourt début
du concert à 16 heures ils partent pour
une tournée aux quatre coins de la
planète les mangeurs de lapin proposent
leurs plus grands numéros de music-hall
un carnet de voyage poétique loufoque et
déjantée à vivre ce mercredi 23 janvier
outre et au théâtre espace coluche de
plaisir extraits
[Musique]
c'est un hommage une déclaration d'amour
que jane birkin ghf et à saint serge
gainsbourg l'artiste fait jouer sa
musique par un orchestre symphonique et
interprète les textes célèbres
elle sera sur la scène de la ferme du
manet de montigny le bretonneux ce
samedi 26 janvier la danseuse et
chorégraphe yasmine hugonnet propose un
concert choréographie qu'aux musiques al
l'artiste s'intéresse à la genèse du
mouvement à la chronologie de l'instant
elle présente chronologique hall le 24
janvier prochain au théâtre de saint
quentin en yvelines événement national
pour célébrer les arts et la culture
dans les conservatoires la nuit des
conservatoires revient pour une sixième
édition et plusieurs établissements
saint quentinois répondent présents
comme attrape ou l'école de musique et
de danse vous permet d'assister à des
cours des répétitions et des parenthèses
musicales et chorégraphiques à plaisir
le château et ses copains se dévoileront
en concert ou encore un mort pas qui
participe pour la première fois à cette
nuit des conservatoires la salle ravel
l'espace albert camus le café de la
plage vous attendent pour de nombreux
concerts ont conclu ce magazine avec un
hommage il était une légende de
l'accordéon marcel azzola s'est éteint
ce lundi 21 janvier chez lui à villennes
sur seine
il accompagnait edith piaf gilbert
bécaud barbara mais aussi jacques brel
qui lui avait lancé un fameux chauffe
marcel chauffe d'écouté
voyager finir meilleur jeune
même au delà
faire l'accordéon
d'abord camille on à paris
g
c'est la fin de cette culture merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]